[Music]
so
[Music]
now who's ready
[Music]
so give it up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up guys how you guys doing
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
a little bit uh
lackluster energy maybe you guys thought
you guys are coming to see a super bowl
party
said we're just going to be
having straight sex up here
the dating show
not uh
not
not going to do watching people play
sports
uh but good to be here
my name is hans kim i smoked a little
bit too much before the show
uh should be a good one so how it works
is i picked two random names out of the
bucket and then we watched two people go
on dates on stage and then after a
minute
me and my wonderful guests interview you
i get to know the dates a little bit
better
and it's a lot of fun
anyways
you guys ready to
watch an insult give you dating advice
well you're in luck because i'm here but
also we've got a wonderful wonderful
human being who happens to be a lady
here as well and she's very funny she's
a comedian from houston uh and she's a
good friend of mine please go for dulce
mac
thank you dulce
with the table service i don't know why
you want it but you look like a jack and
coke guy
it's the most generic drink yeah i think
it makes me look cool if he orders our
jack and coke he's for the streets just
no
i'm a man in the streets yeah and a boy
in the sheets
uh but we got a great show how's your
dating life been dulce oh terrible oh
tell me more
um
i broke up with my boyfriend or he broke
up with me i couldn't keep count
um and now i'm like on three dating apps
but i refuse to meet up with anyone
that's cool make them wait for you you
know keep them on red i hate the whole
like talking on the apps thing
everyone tries to flirt all clever like
with metaphors and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are we talking about yeah use more
similes or alliteration
yeah but it's fun i guess yeah dating
dating's fun yeah i get laid i'm okay
hey
hey
at least one of us is getting light
we got one name of the lgbtqia plus
bucket so i hope you're the a for
asexual
that's all you're gonna be getting
tonight
uh just kidding you wanna pull a name
from the uh
man bucket
if you're gonna tell us i said f before
and i cleverly switched it to an m
for man
oh we got jen coming up as a woman
we got barry
mccarthy how do you say that cochner
barry mcconnell
oh hey barry mccouchner is actually a
woman
yeah i was like a girl wrote this for
sure there's like do you want to be in
the you want to go on a date with a
[Music]
woman was sort of consensual
give it up for barry mccochner
a person who identifies as a woman or
man
but looks like a woman
and jen
they're already flirting with each other
uh keep it going for these two ladies
i'm sorry i thought i was supposed to
put my name in the bucket for who i was
like interested in so
i did men so i did her i i'm sorry
i took a shot before this okay
what do we do i'm so sorry go on a date
with each other go ahead and ask each
other questions
oh okay um
so how long have you lived in austin
uh well i don't live in austin i'm
visiting here with my best friend we've
been here since
thursday
but i live in fort worth
where do you live
i moved here this is actually my one
year anniversary this weekend of living
here
[Music]
you're from florida
oh
i moved here during the snowpocalypse
last year so
that was very eventful uh what made you
want to move here
so i visited my friend who's in the
crowd a couple of years ago
and i just love the energy here in
austin everyone's really cool super
friendly and open
and just came back a couple of years
later is this on i feel like i can't
hear myself
no okay
i have a very different opinion of
austin i've only been here what like
four days
i uh
i don't like it
i mean if if you like austin that's
that's okay i'm sorry i'm such a bad
date wow okay anyways what's your sign
scorpio you're a scorpio oh i'm a gemini
that's a very toxic relationship
and time
give it up for the gemini and scorpio
they're biting each other that's such a
bad date
well the day started off with oh what am
i doing oh we talked to each other okay
i find that's not that they're always
the best i had to watch this podcast
before i came i'm sorry
hey she's new to the podcast today i'm
so sorry i'm so rude i'm so sorry
with the experience on a dating show
like that i think you're a super bowl
fan
uh well i don't go on a lot of dates i
don't yeah i'm so awkward when it comes
to dating when's the last date you've
been on and wasn't at the dallas comedy
club with han skin
okay um
the last date i went on
why are you all trying to embarrass me
like that i don't know wow barry
mccouchner the man
acting like a real woman
um jen uh how do you how do you like the
dating scene in austin a lot of a lot of
good rock climbers you've been on dates
with lately lots of fishermen
just
you came from florida yeah so i came
from south florida
miami [ __ ] boys and here
miami
[Laughter]
is it on
turn her around that's what barry
mcconnell's
been trying to do this whole night
just pretend it's right hello yeah that
sounds better
okay oh yay
now it's on how are the [ __ ] boys
different in florida than here
i feel like a lot of guys are like more
like materialistic i guess and just like
immigrants
here
in florida yeah where the where the
animals are
we're sophisticated human beings in
austin yeah here is just there's like a
lot like a lot of options and i feel
like you just have to be like
on the same page
you're very beautiful though like do you
have like trouble dating or do you just
not want to date
it's just like there's too many options
too many damns
there's a guy who's autistic there's a
guy who's nerdy and autistic
how do you choose between all these
different type of tech workers
so uh what's the last date you've been
on in austin
last year
last year so when you first got here you
were you went on a date
oh last year like a month two months ago
right before uh
you know right during the omicron wave
it was her fault
yeah it was spread mostly through gen
dating yeah
how did yo how did it go where did he
where did he take you
um
so i went to peppermint park
the like uh coda
christmasy themed
yeah actually it was really great
nice that sounds cute barry mccochner
would you where would you tate where
would you take uh jen on a date and
would it be better than peppermint lane
oh i'm really good when it comes to like
planning dates um
i think if so we were like texting or
something i'd probably ask you like
you know oh are there any like specific
foods you like anything you like to do
and that's how we get to know somebody's
like obviously through conversation
that's how we all get to know each other
but like
i really listen and then i'm like what
can i do to like with the information
that i have to like take somebody on a
date but i usually try and do like a
three
i guess like a three-step date so go
somewhere to eat
go like do something and then like maybe
get drinks after or like dessert after
something
so where would you take this scorpio who
loves austin's energy and is from
florida well i don't know about any
places in austin but i guess like fort
worth dallas area i'd probably do like a
nice like dimly lit
sushi restaurant if you like sushi then
maybe after
just walk around like i guess um like
north park area where like the mall is
in like dallas that's a really nice area
some good shops there
and then um
find like a like what a place to get
drinks a wine bar after i don't know
[ __ ] like wine right
i mean [ __ ] like wine do you love
wine
do i like wine um i really don't like
alcohol but i'll drink it because i like
the way it makes me feel
but i like barefoot moscato literally
the cheapest sweetest nasty i like how
you said dimly lit sushi bars yeah
dimly like yeah
to not be able to be visible i want to
see what i'm
eating the sushi
well if it's not a nice restaurant i
think that's quality i think that would
be you know if you're a real man you'd
be like hey why don't you try some of
this sushi it's in my pants
no if i was a real man i'd be like let
me try some of that sushi
yeah put that sushi on the table girl
let's
yeah i'm i'm so sorry i'm so glad it's
deadly
i'm so glad it's dimly lit in here or
else everyone would see us eating each
other's vibe
you think you guys should go on dates
with like real men
maybe we should we should get some men
up here yeah
it's an estrogen fest up here
yeah i feel outnumbered
um
so uh
hello barry mccouchner you wanna
come back we're gonna we're gonna see
jen on like a date with a man and then
we'll bring you up and you can go on a
date with a man just because women can't
that's gonna be so horrible this is
women's girl i got a date with them just
because women you know women can't read
and uh she put her name in the wrong
bucket
but uh yeah yeah give it up for jen and
barry mccochner
we're gonna get jen to go on a date with
a real human mail
[Music]
and barry mccochner is gonna take notes
[Music]
is this a man bucket
i don't know anymore we got only two men
we got grant
give it up for grant coming up here
he's
he's a real man
he doesn't just love men
[Music]
i'm grant i currently identify as a man
good to meet you
[Music]
i can hear you we walked up to the
bucket together did we not yeah you i
walked in and you were like do you want
to put your name in the bucket and i was
like is he one of the people on the
stage like that's what i thought now i
am so
here we are you put your name in the
right bucket uh
it was nice to see you go on a date
beforehand i feel i feel more prepared
just on another date so hopefully this
one's better yeah oh well she seemed
nice
[Laughter]
you were just expecting someone with a
barbecue in their pants not sushi in
their pants yeah or like a
beard uh well i brought a one drink to
stage maybe i should have been a better
date and brought you one as well is
there a is there what do you like to
drink
what was the honey the honey do you want
the honey cave bunny honey
if anyone can hear me that is capable of
purchasing alcohol honeycave would be
fantastic
on uh grant's tab
but uh yeah we can get that arranged for
you and uh like to learn more about you
sure what do you want to know i'm a
scorpio you're a scorpio yeah i'm an
aquarius
what do you think of that
i don't know much about aquarius you
tell me i'm still learning a little bit
myself because uh you're just assaulted
with people asking that question these
days uh i think it means i'm sensitive
um keep it going for grant and jen
he's sensitive ladies
that is a lie
aquarius are not sensitive what does it
mean i want to know
uh well it means you are detached and
by this one minute i know you're a hoe
what a detached hoe
what does it mean if she's a scorpio
she's a
sexy i feel like this is just sexism uh
no it depends
aquarius girls are better than guys it's
like a thing
and yes you are sexist
um
so star signs are
kind of interesting
what uh
what do you what
oh yeah the bar staff
thanks zach
i like how you made that happen that was
good
good point
bought her a drink spent uh about 20
seconds of your 60-second interview
ordering a drink
sure that you can work within society
and
get
where are you from
i'm from up north you may have heard up
north dallas okay
this is the second dallas person you've
been on a date with in five minutes this
is like a trend anyone else from dallas
well she's like northwest fort worth
it's it's totally it's all part of
different oh dad he's so different yeah
he grew up in the white part of dallas
and she grew up in the hood i am white i
know in this light it may be hard to
tell but you can tell i was curious
what's your
last date you've been on with a white
man
and did he take you axe throwing
i haven't ever been axe throwing grant
show her show her your people's ways
okay well i mean i i was just shooting
guns but maybe we could switch it up to
throwing axes the the more traditional
white people way
but we're shooting guns in a school or
in a shooting range
you gotta ask how do you know with my
high school reunion
i uh i don't know about any axe throwing
rangers i guess i haven't been here long
enough to do you know about any hans or
do you
i do not i know there are some
just google it yeah
what you asking us for
this
segment brought to you by google.com and
ask jeeves
uh jen have you ever fired a gun in
anger
this is a very important question it is
i have fired a gun
but i was just scared
and in fear some say that's worse
back in your face and i was like pellets
what what were you shooting are you
shooting a baby gun at your face
yeah wow
please don't give her a gun
i hope you're not a teacher cause you're
about to get a gun i love how she didn't
say what she was shooting she just kept
describing the shells
she's like murdering someone and she's
like these shells are really annoying
are you sure you're not white
like partially no no they would tell you
what they're shooting for sure
premeditated is our way
so how long have you been in texas jen
one year
one year oh you're from florida the
texas of southeast america
so you move from florida to texas
what other [ __ ] state are you going
to move to
alabama or mississippi
no i'm just kidding um interesting move
florida texas
uh what is it what do you think like uh
texas is just like florida except more
deserty less
water less flat
for sure
um
she's not just talking about the ladies
the terrain
i don't know it's just it's just
different you know yeah culturally i
feel like it's very different
yeah is your mic still on
i don't know is it it's owned okay
like i can sure hear you if you go on a
date with him he'll make sure your sound
is working i want you to be
heard oh
what a feminist
give it up for the feminist
grant
what a snake are you sure he's not the
scorpio
he's trying to slither in
what do you think about this couple you
think that they could work out in the
long run
not in the long run but maybe like three
weeks i think it could be fun brutally
honest
could have a nice fling
yeah
where would you take her on a date
god okay so if you're from florida um we
don't have alligators to shoot here but
we could shoot some razorbacks some hogs
i'm wearing my
alma mater right now so if you like to
hunt we could do that or if you like
something a bit more calm we could do
paddle boarding
that's usually my go-to
you know that was starting out there axe
throwing
yeah so you've already shot guns so
we've gotta cover the
whole range of different weapons you can
wield uh i used to have swords
so if you like to cut stuff oh she's
getting wet already yeah tell her about
your sword collection graham swords
you know i used to have uh these ebay
katanas are you familiar oh no not a
katana
you're making our people look bad grant
i shaved my neck beard recently so you
wouldn't know but
uh i definitely enjoy the occasional
fruit ninja play so
okay
so we could throw axes and then adapt at
ipad games too
i played the ipad game
then you already know what to do
so yeah we could we could start with ax
throwing and then when we get real
serious we get down to the fruit ninja
stuff so
that's the plan sounds great
sounds like a dangerous couple
yeah where are you going to go hiking
with axe throwing and knives
jen
what do you think about grant do you
think that he would make a good father
figure
um down the line you know
yeah he would have got he's like and how
old are you 26 just turned 20. he's
already got the dad jokes
yeah yeah yeah maybe thank you like in
the 30s you know
yeah once he's aged out of this weird
[ __ ]
plan
you know
yeah
down the line i could see it yeah you
know if i had to plan it that would
probably be the perfect way to do it in
the 30s have kids and uh
i don't know i think i've got some
growing for sure but i think i think i
see a future with that i want to have
kids i want to have two boys what do you
think about that do you want girls boys
what is your plan
i want
i'd be okay with three but i definitely
want
three issues
whoa they're ready grant you're about to
enter a mexican-american family
so
i'm colombian thank you and
sorry i want to have it like if i had
all girls that'd be great one guy would
be fine but yeah all girls
all guys
okay well what if you just get more
white guys like me that grow their hair
long so you could do their hair just get
a boy with a wig even if i had boys
their hair would be fabulous that's for
sure we just had gay kids
and then they could you could do their
hair and do all the same things but they
could still maybe play football like you
can have all that i don't think her
colombian parents would like
having three gay children yeah what are
your experiences about you living here
in like the gay capital of texas
they don't know
they don't
how do they not know
they don't know
they thought you were kidnapped 10 years
ago in colombia
uh so possible
so uh
you uh you want kids i always love when
a guy with a knife a sword collection
asks how many kids you have i feel like
it's a safe place to tell tell them
your childhood preferences
um
what uh
what kind of concerts have you been to
recently
most recently acl
okay
same that was my last two who did you
see wow i went exclusively for carol g
and it was like my birthday celebration
as well
she is my favorite
carol g
hans that was a great question do you
know who carol g is carol g no i do not
colombian okay i don't feel bad now i'm
like
me too because i thought of a grandma
with like cookies and stuff i don't know
why you were carol what kind of cookies
i just thought of carol g as like a
grandma i don't know why this sounds
like a sweet name yeah she's colombian
you said so she's like that's how you
relate to her did you see her before she
became big in america
not in person that was my first time
seeing her in person but i've just loved
her forever oh that's awesome
i saw she was in the lineup i'm like
that's why i'm going i thought carol g
was a guy in the hood that went around
caroling during christmas
a carol gangster
so y'all were both at acl yeah
wow look how cute you guys
yeah i i saw miley cyrus
i loved miley yeah i was a big hannah
montana guy you know growing up
dizzy channel
[ __ ] miley any of her songs
[Laughter]
nobody's perfect so i gotta work it
again and again until i get it
right you should
delta is about to steal her her man
i think
uh so jen uh do you think uh that you're
gonna see grant again and uh where would
you take him
you gotta eliminate axe throwing now so
you gotta come with your own thing i
would say like rock climbing i thought
you put that in my head you think grant
would be good at rock climbing it would
take him like two steps to get to the
top yeah two years you just have to
reach i also have a fear of heights you
can do the bouldering yeah i'm scared of
heights too but why are we doing this
that's why you gotta do it we should go
to a water park instead i think that's
leave it to the colombians and try to
climb a wall on a date uh
we have uh plane tickets
no just kidding i'm from south korea um
it's the uh yeah we were really poor for
a while
sports
barbecue um what are the other like main
things south korea is known for
horror movies okay
kdrama k-pop oh yeah i don't know i
forgot north korea
north korea is like venezuela it's a
north south rivalry
uh so jen do you think that uh
you would date a white man or are you
mostly exclusively looking in the latino
director did you say you dated a white
man earlier
avoided the question earlier i wasn't
allowed to answer the question but this
is my first
date with the white guy in a long time
the way it should be thank you for
keeping uh away from white men for this
long i'm sorry to break your streak am i
a good representation of our of our
culture am i am i representing us well
right now
got the sweater you got me a drink
you know you're gonna expand my
knowledge of artillery and
weaponry of course
so i think yeah
she's gonna take it back to colombia and
train the farc i think one white man a
year is okay yeah so that could be my
quota a way man a year
keeps the tax man away
or something keeps your credit score
high if you need someone to do your
taxes uh i won't do them but i can pay
someone else too so awesome we'll take
care of it give it up for grant and jen
they went on a date
they're going to exchange numbers
let's get barry mccockener up here again
barry mccochner
let's get on barry up here and let's
find a beautiful man for her today
uh there's only one left is cody
cody you're going on a date with barry
cody and barry
thank you that's the more visual seat
and cody
[Music]
hello
what is your actual name i can't i i
just can't keep up with the very joke um
my girl name's marissa nice to meet
you nice to
we have differing opinions about it
because i love it here yeah i mean
there's there's definitely good places
here i think if you come down here with
a good group of friends you can have a
really good time
just not everybody here i think is
well i won't talk anything bad about the
city or the people
i've lived here my whole life so i'm
definitely biased i have a complete and
utter
um
love for my my home state and
capital i'm just rambling now yeah no i
i love texas too i love texas i i love
my home state but have you traveled a
lot or no uh i have almost exclusively
east i haven't really gone west so far
as
west texas i went to grand canyon state
park and that's as far west as i've ever
gone wow do you smoke you look like you
smoke i'm dead
yeah i smoke a lot too do you have like
a van or you look like this no i have an
apartment you have an apartment i do
pretty well for myself actually oh my
gosh i just i locked into a door
drug test i work for a video game
company
a video game
oh my god y'all i found my husband
literally end time give it up for the
lovely couple
they're gonna have an eight-bit wedding
so uh
cody you kind of uh defended your home
city there
uh
really showing uh marissa why she hates
austin is the uh
laid-back energy
all they're just robbing now
you look like sex on stage i thought
that was what we were doing
marissa you said that austin would be
great if you had a good group of friends
i feel sorry for the group of friends in
the audience that you brought tonight
apparently not giving you the show that
you deserve no no no no i love everybody
that i've met here in austin oh almost
so far yeah everybody that i'm with has
been very very good who's the weirdest
person you've met i haven't
oh i don't know if you want me to say
that that's going to get a little messy
it's hans we got him i'm the weirdest
i don't think you're the weirdest but i
think just
so i'm from fort worth i have
never seen
so many men dressed like women and so
many crackheads out on the street i'm so
sorry
but just a lot of
weird people walking on the street
yeah this is like uh if someone from the
50s came to the present time they're
like what's with all these men dressed
like woman
what is this a hair metal band
um yeah i mean we got a lot of
crackheads here uh it really adds to the
scene
um you know we got a rich vibrant
homeless community that cody is trying
to imitate right now
cody you can't say that there are no
crackheads here i haven't seen anything
you haven't seen any
there's one i've been recognizing
well
when i see a disenfranchised person i
don't assume they they do crack no i
assume they're poor and they can't
afford it jesus
he calls them disenfranchised people i
got a little what are they like a
mcdonald's that went out of business
sometimes
disenfranchised
we need to get this guy a franchise he
looks like he's disenfranchised he was
almost an english teacher can you tell
oh my gosh well
what a bleeding heart
he loves the people even the smelly ones
that look like they do crack
he won't assume that they do crack
um cuddy what do you think about uh
houston would you ever uh dallas would
you ever go to fort worth
uh yeah i've been to dallas a couple of
times i don't know if i've been to fort
worth specifically but i've been in that
general area um for a few different
things
and what what how would you describe it
it's texas um i like texas just
generally as a whole i feel like um
the dallas fort worth area is the more
uh
suit and tie business part of texas
whereas like east texas houston is like
your industry area
they're like hard hat workers yeah it's
a generalization i know but there's not
as many crackheads
you don't like a good city
if it doesn't have crackheads in it
i i don't i don't see drug use i'm like
i'm like drug lying
people are really drug blind you just
see suppliers and plugs
but if a homeless person is like very
awake at like 3 a.m and they ask you for
six dollars crackhead because they
they already have 14
and they need a full 20 you know
that's how i know you're so funny all
right
she's from venezuela
she's actively uh pushing her drugs on
us right now yeah let me know after the
show
so cody what's the craziest drug you've
done on sixth
street uh none on sixth street uh safe
space it's all about setting setting
setting settings set and setting set and
settings yes so where do you do it in
your van my apartment lsd is probably
that or mushrooms i don't know which
experience was more hard they're about
equal but yeah okay pretend you're on
lsd or mushrooms right now what would
you be like on a date
uh i'd probably be even more kind of
spaced out that i am currently
uh i'd probably be staring off into the
distance and looking for something to do
and talking a lot about space
yeah
oh my god typical white guy [ __ ] oh yeah
so let's just pretend that you guys are
on a date and
uh
cody is
out of his mind on acid
uh and action
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now are
you really on acid on our date
i was told that it would enhance
my
your sense of self the wrong idea oh
i wanted to get in touch with
and you
and everyone
i really just wanted to understand how
it all just fits together you know
security
security
people are clapping that means the scene
is over
the people are the director then they
say cut
either that or i'd probably beat your
ass honestly well that's good
i don't have those
are you usually rubbing your nipples
on acid ah i do a lot of
textile just whatever i end up touching
i spent half an hour crumbling ramen the
last time i was stoned
nice like just texture luckily you live
in a home
what's your deepest psychological scar
oh damn
[Music]
i'm on a date i have to know this
this is literally what i ask people i'm
not even joking
it's probably
something to do with blood because i
just get
to pass out normally
nothing in your childhood like my own
blood
uh
no
probably something related to blood in
my childhood that traumatized me look at
his head banned he hasn't had any trauma
in his life ever
[Laughter]
he's too relaxed to have trauma
you could have used a good molestation
when it might have made you interesting
i don't think about my past very often
oh my god
barry mcconnell marissa what's your
biggest psychological trauma
um
i'll tell you one of the biggest ones so
the first time i had ever smoked weed i
was like 14 years old hey welcome to
fort worth
um and i was at my friend's house and
during the night her mom had died
and her dad
asked us to go and check on her mom to
see her stepmom
to see if she was still alive
and i think probably seeing that yeah
that was one of my deepest psychological
wow that sounds like a dare program
story
don't do drugs
[Music]
and he's fine
let's do drugs and try to forget about
it
i've literally been trying so hard
that's crazy and you still smoke lots of
weed so i do smoke a lot of weight
you're like let me go back to that
moment again it's medicinal
right it is well
it's it's called experiment because i
don't know if that's part of this
if you're a step mom don't let marissa
smoke any weed around you you might end
up dead
uh so cody how do you feel about hearing
that you think that uh that's that's
kind of an intense story
what do you think what would you uh
what would you say to a date who told
you that i feel
very odd because i'm grappling for a
similar experience to kind of share as
well but i really don't have anything uh
[ __ ] crazy you do not want stories
like this i'm [ __ ] crazy
i let a very sheltered life uh i grew up
in the suburbs very standard issue white
boy you said you smoked 14. i was 19 and
set and setting i like planned out my
day it's like okay i'm gonna get the day
off of work i don't know how it's gonna
affect me no i saw somebody like
like recovery planned and then i woke up
and i was like well [ __ ] i got a whole
day off work now what am i gonna do
how many relationships have you been in
i had one serious relationship
oh my god the cheating redhead yes
really the cheating rock
yes
he's a little bitter about it
i can't say it right whoever you are
[ __ ] that redhead all right on behalf of
cody yeah cody's a nice man he could be
your weed accountant yes
he could be this person on earth
i'm kind of jealous at first i was like
who is this guy and i'm like i wish i
was you
oh thank you that's a weird compliment
but i appreciate it well we've been
through a lot
yeah you have to go through a lot i was
literally just about to say you're a
pisces huh
uh i feel like we would kind of work out
but
i'm still pretty young and i'm still
pretty toxic
and i'm a gemini and i'm really hot so
i'm like i don't know i'd probably do
you wrong somehow
and i would regret it for the rest of my
life though you would literally be the
one that got away if i did well i guess
thank you but i think you're you're
putting yourself down because here's
here's a secret my mother worked for a
newspaper back in the day when that was
like social media was he just read the
newspaper and everyone had the same
thing to talk about she was in charge of
the horoscope and she only paid for
one year's worth of horoscopes and she
just shuffled them
and pulled
yeah never got any complaints
everyone was very certain the horoscope
was spot on and
life
that's so interesting well you got to
get marissa to smoke weed around her
maybe she'll end up dead for that it's
kind of a serious crime
give it up for marissa and cody
they went on a date together
give it up for them they're gonna do
good the uh nerdy uh guy that is boring
and the uh girl that will knife you in a
fight
uh maya is the girl coming up
we got amaya coming up
there she is
and then for the man we got the
cameraman himself mr sam [ __ ]
kuiper
from alabama the alabama thunder
i hope you're his cousin
and if you're a man please sign up we
need more men
one of the weird situations where we
have too many women hi and give it up
for sam and maya again
maya
i'm sam hi sam nice to meet you nice to
meet you too are you from austin i'm not
i'm from pittsburgh pennsylvania okay
what how long you've been in are you
visiting are you living here i've been
here three years about three years oh
okay yeah
do you regret it
so i used to um but i think what the
majority of my time here has been during
the pandemic so yeah it's actually
gotten a lot better since things have
been opening up is that okay yeah
exactly yeah so you guys like before the
pandemic right
yeah yeah 2019. and then everything just
crashed and it was a boring yeah well
the whole world was boring for a little
bit but
yeah
where are you from um alabama originally
oh okay i've never met anyone from
alabama i think one interested there we
go yeah well yeah i've met one person
from alabama yeah
we like to date our sisters so we don't
get out that much you know
i heard about you over there how dare
you judge me
you better
you look like my sister what what's your
name oh [ __ ]
maybe she should be up here no i don't
have a sister last time you went on a
date with someone who wasn't your sister
uh
actually uh like a week ago but um
you know okay so you're out on these
streets i'm out on these streets i do it
again how long have you been in austin
about 10 months oh 10 months okay i was
in los angeles but like as the pandemic
started um and then
everything shut down that was like a
scary place to be so
i moved in with my parents and they live
in dallas and then uh just to like see
what was gonna happen and then i was
like this also was not the place to be
so i had to [ __ ]
i'm 32 and that was the first time
moving back home since i moved out and
uh
end time
in time give it up for sam and maya
i like it though i like austin yeah sam
going with the bold move of admitting
that he moved in with his parents at age
32. yeah he dates his sister
how does that usually work out when you
tell people that you moved in with your
parents at 32. you know i like was
hesitant at first but like i really
don't give a [ __ ] uh i'm well off i do
well i don't need to and you were single
you want to go back home and date around
a little bit inside your family well
like la just was like everything shut
down in la and then like this was also
in the beginning of like
the pandemic and it was kind of like
presented as an apocalypse and i was
like well los angeles i was living in
hollywood i was going to film school
and uh i love how it's presented as an
apocalypse well like at first everyone's
pr was like what's gonna happen this
apocalypse yeah where did you go to film
school uh los angeles film school me too
did you yeah
[ __ ] hell yeah a couple of laughs alum
yep alumni yeah you got it right last
how do you know you're all educated
probably i guess i love acronyms
i'm a little autistic
um so what did you learn in laughs
uh so i have a background i've always
done like acting in theater so i've
always been in front of the camera but i
wanted to like start making movies and
learn the other side of the camera so
like i'm tired of fame and success yeah
i'm tired of all these how do i do a lot
of hard work no recognition hide myself
more yeah but amaya where did you go to
school i went to the university of
michigan sorry yeah go wolverines like i
was slurring but i'm university of
michigan university of michigan yeah
don't worry
i studied organizational studies which
is what hard to explain is that just
post-it notes
kind of post-it notes and binders
[Music]
what do you do what's your job i do ux
design ux design yeah what is that
oh thank you oh my god give it up for a
grant i feel like i made a case for not
needing more drinks he's giving drinks
to ladies that aren't his date now how
dare you so much attention
this guy um could i get a corn dog too
oh hey me too thank you
speaking of using metaphors
um so you studied organizational skills
organizational studies studies
so you studied how to study organizing
things yes yeah
social sciences what did you learn i
learned um i should have gone to
business school
or engineering school or
pre-med that's what i learned anything
but uh something that a kindergartner
learns on the first day of school yeah
uh that sounds really i've never heard
of anyone that studied like the concept
of organizing stuff
well it's like yeah it's social sciences
but yeah it was very
free
free spirited choosier classes
yeah it was no laughs we'll let you
graduate there was no la film school no
certainly not no
well you could uh use a little
organizing couldn't you and your film
endeavors yeah organization is always
maybe when you guys shoot your first
porn together as a couple
i'll help you organize the tape
yeah
the scene right like i got the schedule
the semen goes in here sam you gotta
organize this
you can't just shoot it all over the
place
um so what do you think about uh sam do
you think that uh his alabama ways could
be tamed thank you grant
um grant's giving drinks to dudes now
whoa he's playing the field
yeah very progressive of you sir
well i think he's showing progress by
having moved to austin so i think
the alabama might be leaving his system
thank god i think there's hope for him
not a moment too soon yeah
he was about to send you across the
border but uh thankfully he's progressed
to loving gay people now
i love when you said alabama you said
the sister thing immediately he's like i
know where you're going i know you're
going to say i had to just nip in the
bud you know like before the
sam what's the most alabama thing about
you that you still do to this day
no i don't i don't have a sister she
makes love to it so i can't but i would
if she existed no i'm just kidding um
uh i don't know man i drink cheap beer
and i like [ __ ]
live music uh like with the guitars
a country boy you like leonard skinner
yeah
i do
man maya
would you ever go to like a country
music concert with this guy and i could
yeah i could do that hold this cowboy
hat up as he pukes i've been to a kenny
chesney concert
he's a good concert i've been i've been
to a kenny chesney concert he puts on a
good show i don't know
we have so much in common we are yeah i
think so what what what's your type of
music you is it not country it sounds
like usually like alternative rock or
indie yeah so like okay give me your
favorite band right now um right now
lord here on
i have no clue here
she's from uh michigan state is i'm from
pennsylvania but i went to michigan yeah
is that like the like
they're they named themselves after the
lake huron is that what i believe so
yeah i think they're from michigan wow
this alabama kid went to school i know
he did lake huron i went to a few
schools
so uh
lake here uh what did you say master
here on
george here on that's some real axe
throwing music sam she's whiter than you
are yeah
um would you ever go axe throwing
i would yes have you been no i have not
no it's like a thing like it's it's like
it's like paddle boarding i think my
favorite date was topgolf so i have
white tendencies
do good in austin yeah i've done top
golf never axe throwing either though i
mean it seems fun but
yeah sam does more axe swallowing what's
your
what was your i don't even know what
that
your favorite date you've been on my
favorite date
um
i go on so many no uh
topgolf is fun i like to do that
i don't like to go to the movies i don't
like to just like let's go get i don't
like to be cliche like let's go do
something and then like laugh at each
other like if i suck at topgolf like no
big deal what do you think about that
answer
the one he just yeah i don't like to do
things i like to do i like to do things
he doesn't like to do quiet things i
don't like to do cliche i want to be
able to interact i don't want to go to a
movie and not be able to like talk to
you like that's yeah it's like i get
that fourth or fifth date maybe
i don't know my last date took me to
dairy queen
what did you get a blizzard i did did
they turn it upside down
no i didn't know about that until what
they didn't do it no so were they like
do you know what we do here no he told
me after
i didn't text him back again sure you
got your money well when you're a dairy
queen you have to talk to each other
it's not like a movie at all that's true
but i was just sharing a shitty day
experience
yeah a little dairy queen
no i did have a bad date at a movie
and i get what he's talking about like
we got there and then we couldn't talk
so i just we just sat there in silence
and it was really awkward sounds like
little date to me
if you don't like the guy
yeah yeah but he didn't talk after
either so maybe it was me but he's just
a really good movie watcher
he's just like i'm in the zone don't
you can like touch hands or something
you know body language
yeah he wasn't even doing that he didn't
even go for the dick and the popcorn no
what a [ __ ] or anything
hey i just gotta cut this hole real
quick though
i looked for it show some initiatives
that's my favorite move
i love why you're so quiet and you say
the wildest things
it's great do you ever get mad like do
you yell yeah
do i have a cat no i have a dog
oh thank god i'm shaped like a cat
though
what kind of dog is that she's a
chihuahua terrier oh cute with some sexy
cat curves
at that nice cat desk yeah
so uh
have you ever who do you usually get mad
at like customer service um yes
strangers usually when i'm driving yes
i get mad at other drivers what's your
favorite insult when you're driving and
you get mad um just like [ __ ] you
but
stick with the classics yeah pretend
you're driving and someone pisses you
off
this guy's in a pickup truck demon over
here oh demon
that's so like unbreakable kimmy schmidt
that's pretty accurate
that's adorable i uh i would love to see
you get angry at grant or uh sam right
now
well i don't see my phone you scaly well
i might get mad where's this corn dog
she ordered she's getting hangry
she didn't forget about the corn dogs
yeah so i would never forget
you do see if i don't have food i do get
very angry i was gonna say you seem like
you flip a switch real quick like you're
quiet and reserved and then you're just
like god damn it you just like why is
this
why is this not organized
i went to school for this exactly
yeah that sounds right
well don't uh get mad in front of sam
cause they'll film you in crystal clear
hd 4k i will and then i'll never live it
down i'll cancel you i'll [ __ ] put it
out there
one of the rare
uh male on female cancelings yeah
so uh sam what's the
what's the last time you've been
canceled
luckily not yet i try to stay away from
any like
you know possibilities of offending
people i i'm a nice guy really like i
talk a lot of [ __ ] uh but i don't
think i
ever
approach that line of where it's like
well maybe too far i try to stay away
from that oh i love watching white men
apologize
you didn't even do anything no i won't
either i won't like i'm a nice guy yeah
i haven't said the n word in like 10
years
well depends if i like lil wayne so
when i'm by myself i will maya do you
love
maya do you love rap music um i could i
could get into it it's not my first
choice is there any uh rap song that you
know the lyrics to by heart uh
no no
damn i really wanted to see you rap me
too uh no what if i think if like the
music's playing i could probably get
like a few
like i'll jump in every now and then
let's play uh n words in paris on the
loudspeakers
see which part maya knows the words to
um so you guys are a very beautiful
couple i mean you guys should really go
on a date maybe to like a bookstore or
like a coffee shop
what makes you say that
you guys are both like very like you
know you're you're talking and listening
and you're not like interrupting each
other oh okay i see i thought it was the
card again i was going to say the card
again it's like uh
that's definitely part of it okay yeah
it's an unconscious bias i know do you
listen to npr i do my sister's honor
you have the voice my sister's on npr
she's a reporter yeah oh wow what is she
does she have a show is she just like uh
and business kind of stuff okay oh god
what a depressing job to have the
economics of pittsburgh
in the news today we still have no new
businesses moving in she did a report on
farmers in the pa area
recently so you take what you get
farmers yeah
good for her
hopefully she's farming some of that
i dick know i wish we could do that that
would be fun you have the perfect voice
for npr can you do like yeah does your
sister just do an impression of you when
she's on her job we have similar voices
can you do an npr headline
bomb
today's top stories
hello pittsburgh
give it up for the npr
natural over here
you
even have the cardigan friend beer you
sound like you would do the late night
show like easing people to bed all right
for tonight pittsburgh what we're gonna
do
talk about economy and i don't know
we're gonna listen to the sounds of
bridges collapsing yeah asmr
that was good that was good that was
great i was not scared at all yeah yeah
it's just nice quiet asmr until someone
cups cuts maya off and then she's like
[ __ ] you you [ __ ]
speed demons
speed racer all right give it up for
maya and grant or uh sam
very nice
they both hate the super bowl in
football
where are you for baby i need a drink
where did he go
whiskey soda
this is a woman's there's
there's one more name here i picked this
one out and myla
mila
mila going on a date with spencer
a real man
give it up for spencer and mila
i think we got spencer coming up here
mila mila hello
mila is
nowhere to be seen
do we have a female volunteer to step in
for mila
thank you grant
i'm all alone up here
we need one more
female volunteer
mila did not show up
we need one more person to go on a date
hey
here we go we got mysterious female
number one coming up to go on a date
with
what's his name what's your name spencer
kate kate and spencer give it up for
kate and spencer hi
oh yeah we should talk huh
hi hi how are you
i'm good how are you i'm okay
how long have you been in austin all the
questions
uh 48 hours
no way really
yes where
from
uh i'm i live in dallas okay yes why are
you here uh i'm here
valentine's day yeah yeah okay
did you hear about this beforehand
no i actually just i heard about this
like a couple of hours ago
yeah same yeah
yeah so
this is fun what are those days where
you go out day drinking and then like
three o'clock like what else is going on
and you check do five one two and you're
like okay okay yeah i guess i'll do that
so here i am
do you want a drink by the way that
other guy did that so i can do that
um
do you want to take a shot
oh god
yeah okay what what what do you want
what are you a vodka person a vodka
person yeah
okay i'm a tequila person you can be
whatever kind of person you want to be
tequila shot then
uh i don't have a tab but yeah vodka
a baby bomb actually would be killer
actually green tea i just want to be a
little bit mellow today because i drive
home i don't even want the shot you did
the whole thing
i'm good actually i'm just encouraging
you to take it off speaking to the void
that's fine end time give it up for
spencer and kate
they uh
spent about uh 30 seconds on the date
ordering a drink and then canceling it
great time you guys could do that twice
next time fill up a whole minute
um so
uh what made you come up tonight did you
uh did you uh see your friend go on a
date and you were like i gotta get i
gotta try that i think i always wanted
to come up here but you know i just need
a
little push
for my best
tired of hearing you crying all all
night
she's the pusher
she she just broke up i mean like she's
having a relationship issue and i'm just
a support here oh i just want to show
her
what's out there in the sea yeah you
could date this
this uh california beach bum that uh
turned to skating late in life
yeah so spencer how did you uh
enjoy this date and uh great it's
wonderful had a wonderful time
have you uh been on lots of dates in
austin no
oh i've been isolating man
you've been quarantining no just like
isolating oh okay
just not
not getting to
stay people
i mean i just yeah it's kind of hard to
do that when you're just
shoving [ __ ] away
every second of the day
no
because i have a uh
i have a big like social media thing and
i try and stay away from that that's
good elsewise what do you mean an only
fans or yeah yeah but i only have one
picture of my ass and it's 10 grand a
month he's getting paid for that guys
give it up for him thank you thank you
can i ask about your tattoos yeah which
one what is that like it's not a snake
or this is a double-headed snake and
that's a hand holding a flower and
that's another flower and that's a pair
of boobies uh but it's a
it's a 13.
what it's a 13. yeah
which means it was
dollars right thirteen dollars you see
that yeah okay cool just stop just
making sure no i got it it's friday
thirteenth tattoo so thirteen dollars
you got all your tattoos on your left
hand are you by chance right handed i am
yes so you drew all those yourself no i
don't like to get my own work on me but
you're a tattoo artist no it's just like
a regular one oh okay a regular one
i'd love to be a tattoo artist but
there's
you gotta make connections and stuff you
gotta
yeah it's hard unless you know someone
that does it it's tough you isolate too
much to do that exactly so i don't do
that
why do you isolate what are you doing
there i'm seared
you're what you're sad you're sad yeah
no i isolate too but i'm curious what
you do
yeah your apartment you're there you
just sit around and i don't know just
sit yeah you don't watch anything
so okay so
used to have spectrum internet right but
went through a period where i couldn't
pay my bill and they were just like well
[ __ ] you pal that's it and so they'll
just keep charging you and eventually
got to the point where
i just don't have internet at my place
now and i just kind of you know use my
phone's internet which is just great
really works well so i don't watch a lot
of stuff
i try to when i can
so i just scroll on my phone man
nice i don't have wi-fi at your place
i tore a lot of stuff so if you're
worried about
stuff to watch
i'm well taken care of but if you need
to scroll like facebook
or just check your aol
did you say you tore into a lot of stuff
i do yeah man your fashion sense and
your internet browsing
patterns or that of a 16 year old thank
you do you like my shirt i got it today
yeah it looks great man thank you thank
you sound like a hairy dominatrix it's
like a [ __ ] thing
uh a [ __ ] thing yeah have you been
flower or it's uh yeah so i'm actually
not socially allowed to say the name of
the artist um because it involves the f
word but they're fantastic oh yeah don't
say the [ __ ] word on this podcast you
don't want to do that
upstanding uh show but uh this is okay
last one so i got it so kate how did you
uh
end up coming to austin and uh
how do you enjoy it so far um i actually
did i was actually
um on a tinder date and
we've been knowing each other for a
while and so i just came down here to
see if there's gonna
be any
further wow
i didn't i don't think were you
catfished did you get laid
i did
yes
congrats
come to austin for the dick i have
before
when i didn't live here
and was it worth it
yeah
totally
like a mystery dick you only get it like
once a month so you just
well like a candy you don't want to have
it all the time well i had it for eight
years and now he just gives me free weed
so yeah yeah upgrade that's better than
getting laid
especially if you have a stepmother you
want ted
uh so you uh you went on this date with
this tinder match
that you knew for a long time and now
you're here on a date with
a guy that uh looks like the
stereotypical guy that you cheat with
thank you
thank you
he's cleaner than he looks
well yeah it depends on which area
you're looking at
i'm looking all over buddy that shirt
doesn't leave much to the imagination it
doesn't look they only he had as small
as the last one and i already said i was
interested in it where am i going to
walk away
yeah you don't have to support support
creators all right he'll wear your shirt
no matter how small it is sell them your
baby t-shirts if you got too many of
them exactly uh so kate what what
happened to this tinder date that you
knew for a while he's just so boring
he's a tech guy who works at ibm yeah
wait a minute you're telling me there's
a tech guy in austin that's boring yeah
wow there's not too many of those out
here it's he he makes
a lot of money
and
he doesn't spend it so i just wasn't
sure what's the point of
having him around because like if we go
all the e
what is the point of having him around
you're making but you're not spending
any so what is the point he doesn't even
money's very important to you then he
said he buy his clothes from walmart and
okay
because which ones walmart has some good
heads
okay but i'm saying he he and he's a he
believes in demon he he which one he's a
satanic guy you ended up dating the same
guy
that's why i was like am i in the wrong
place but
sorry go back to that he says satanic
guys
but he's interested in one specific
demon or just satan
apparently there's a satanic temple in
austin that's what i heard and
that's like a go yeah i think you'll
like that
it's
i haven't been yes but i really want to
but he only plan on
going over there
i do want to just check it out so all he
does is go to a satanic lodge don't send
money and lay down good dick yes
his dick works and he his dick
you drove hours for a satanic dick
at the tamp at the temple what is what
are they doing there i i'm not really
sure i think they just there's a goat um
on the satanic thing and i think they
just
praise it man white people be tripping
huh exactly
what is wrong with these people they
make money they don't spend it i know so
i'm just so confused that's why i might
as well get a dick and get it all here
hell yeah yeah you met spencer yeah yeah
a guy who loves jesus right sure do you
you make money and you spend it
yeah yeah man do you praise goats too
do i praise them yes no ghosts
there i i like i'm like you get out of
here ghost but i don't know goats
oh yeah absolutely
yeah he feeds them his shirts after he's
done with them
i mean i don't interact with many of
them but i feel like every time i've
seen a goat i have been like
hey goat not like you know [ __ ] off goat
he's very goat friendly yeah so you can
bring him to your satanic temple if
you're ever going
um cool have you ever dated a white man
funny thing i only date white man
like every asian woman i know
only white man
you know i just think it can get me up
to the level of you know
it really give me some little pride
people don't know about asian people is
that we're very practical yes
we uh we know what's what the game is
and we play it um but yeah no i uh
totally love white women if any are
listening i'd love to date you date up
but honestly um i'm an asian man i don't
really get to pick
um but how do you uh how do you like
austin so you're from dallas right yes
i'm trying actually trying to move down
here but
some i think everyone's going to hate me
because everyone want to move to austin
why
because it's overpopulated every time i
come here the wi-fi just so slow
hey you should know your spectrum got
cut off yeah yeah yeah you're right well
once you're here for three months then
that's it then other people who are here
then you know no one's gonna pay
attention to you they're gonna be paying
attention to people who are here now so
very small amount of time for people to
kind of be like
okay i like how when you said your
internet didn't work kate was like
concerned she was like that's a huge
turn off
uh good news so we're getting google
fiber in a week so
ccp handler all the good news about
america yeah
semester so uh
what do you do in austin you uh do a lot
of uh sword swallowing or
yeah always swallow always swallow spit
out the swords i'm sorry candle
uh
yeah i don't know man i just draw go to
coffee shops and draw you're an artist
yes you make money you make you pay for
your apartment that you stay in all day
yes through art yes wow
what was your yeah give it up for him
what would your asian parents think
about dating a guy who draws for a
living
i'll stick with the ibm guy
it's good honestly you need i mean i'm
i've got like five years left and then i
don't know what i'm gonna do so if you
need the security that's the right call
what a nice guy five years love that's
like a really sad estimate i'm sure i'll
be fine yeah he's gonna die of a heroin
overdose i have no retirement plans i
don't know what i'm gonna do i have no
savings
all right yeah i wish you luck thank you
luckily you invested in tattoos hell
yeah i've got like seven
and i'm sure they'll the value will rise
over time yeah just frame that t-shirt
that's what i'm honestly
be like spilled the rest of my beer all
over myself what a great way to end this
do you skateboard no i used to you never
got around in fact i was a [ __ ]
inline skater an inline skater oh no
so uh i'll still go i'll go to a skating
rink but i'll be the guy who's just
doing it's just way too much he's just
like he's [ __ ] swimming around
did you do tricks did you go off ramps
yeah man yeah that's cool it was fun
yeah if you're just skating around uh
dodging cups that's not as cool
well you kind of have to do that from
all the skateboarders throwing cups at
you like get the [ __ ] out of the state
park you know you should go to a
marathon and just like beat
i everyone you're allowed can you do
that did you go to a marathon and where
just try it
yeah give it a shot
just give it a go yeah kate katie
kate
kate uh so what did you what did you
think about uh spencer do you think that
you think about me sort of like an
artist he's like sort of a maverick i do
want yeah like the sarah palin type what
i do want to get a tattoo maybe we can
do like a matching tattoo thing okay
i'm telling your parents kate i have to
as an agent
yeah okay that means you can't be buried
in a jewish cemetery so just if you have
any plans of doing that you can't do
that anymore can we do like a goat like
a tattoo go we can [ __ ] a ghost oh ghost
tattoo yeah yes
goat tattoo goat let's see twice
twice i've done that
how about a ghost goat
i think i think uh he's afraid that
you're going to ghost him that's why he
keeps hearing i'm afraid you're going to
goat me and that's a whole different
thing
that i'm worried about
that's where you eat that awful shirt
off his body
no your shirt is amazing thanks man
thank you i like it yeah it's really
cool
spencer what the [ __ ] is up with you man
you're like so interesting you're like a
lot of energy you're an interesting
fella thank you you look like uh one of
the robbers in home alone became a [ __ ]
boy
yeah yeah okay you look like you cried
to simple plan or like chemical romance
yeah yeah like you listen to good
charlotte as a child
yeah man yeah absolutely
who's your favorite band right now or do
you want like a funny answer do you want
a real a funny answer please
uh uh duran duran that's who i saw at
acl went specifically for duran duran
you know they've got that song on the
goes
we are
are you skating to duran duran what is
this motion yeah
inline skating the driver evolution of
skanking to scott dance i think kind of
do one of these
yeah thank you scott reference i would
love to see you guys date and i would
love to see you berate him for like
something like why are you wearing your
shoes in-house
that's fine
it's fine i'm kind of into that sort of
dynamic
so that's fine
what uh what kind of asian are you
i think you can guess it chinese
clothes but i wouldn't say that i
thought you were taiwanese yes i am
taiwanese
from the island what about you i think
you're korean yeah south korea did you
say that earlier yeah i did
you could tell because of uh how i'm a
gemini and i have the north part in the
south part
like the north part wants to be a
communist but the south part wants me to
find a girlfriend who makes a lot of
money and spends it at the same time
yes
yeah
so is there a large taiwanese community
in dallas
no there's not that's why i'm trying to
get
out because there's a bunch of old
people there but uh i really like dallas
just because that's where i first moved
there so it's still a home to me isn't
that crazy to move to america than move
to dallas texas
i know it's not how i was expected when
i
when i first got here when i was 12.
what did you expect i really thought it
was gonna be like
just cowboy hats and just everyone has
like three cowboy hats on you know like
okay but then when i got out of the
airport just highways and highways yeah
trucks trucks and yeah that's well it's
not going to be american flags america
it's going to be right outside the
airport you don't get out of the airport
and it's like whoa hey you know yeah but
you think it's just
lizzie mcguire exactly that's why you
get here you're like what the [ __ ] is
this and then they make fun of your
accent and it's really hard
and i've never seen like an extra extra
extra large
cup ever in my life but that was very
interesting oh yeah okay i thought you
just meant you've never seen one just in
general i was like that's cool i've
never also seen a big cup
[Music]
dope
yeah i mean uh americans drink a lot
that's why there's so many buckies
everywhere
bucky says the best logo when i got here
i love the bucky's logo because he's
just like
hey
you don't know where he's looking
look at the next time look at the
bucky's logo we're trying to try and
like
figure out where he's going okay it
looks like he's coked out for sure yeah
maybe that could be your next tattoo
it's bucky's
it's been done too many times yeah
um
buckies
sleepy
okay that's original yeah
so if you took him back to taiwan what
do you think people would say about this
wild american man
honestly
i think he will have fun though because
you know it's i'll have fun that's why
you'll have fun
you'll have a lot of fun but what will
be the perception of me
i'm not really sure you could it's fine
that's very polite people will think you
worship goats and
say yes they probably would they will
ask you about if you can teach them how
to skate and all that even though you
don't on the street don't just come up
to me and ask me that yeah you do look
like
you know
that's fine i'm ready let's go i'll pack
my bags okay
hey one of the good ones spencer and
kate
give it up for that what a wonderful
time
he's gonna go to asia soon
uh the lgbtq bucket
we got barry mccogner in there again
morgan did you want to come up
who is barry
morgan
come up here
morgan going on a date with bernard
give it up for bernard
we got a bernard in the audience oh
there he is
bernard and morgan
going on a date
with some soothing music hey morgan
[Music]
hi
hello hello hi how you doing
how old are you
i'm not old enough to be your father but
old enough to be your
[Laughter]
oh
daddy
how old are you oh i'm 23. oh [ __ ]
okay
this is new
this is a
out of my comfort zone
where are you from i'm from fort worth
all right all right i got family up
there i was uh that's where some of my
family's from a bunch of cousins fort
worth yeah it's
all right with your hostel
like cat gang trees
sure
[Laughter]
oh my god this is so weird for me
what's your favorite color
purple
that's one of my favorite colors oh yeah
orange what's your favorite anime oh my
god why did you ask me that oh cause i
feel like this bizarre adventure
[Music]
that's so funny okay i'm an anime fan i
love the enemy you know
demon hunter
i haven't watched
oh what the [ __ ]
what's your favorite girl anime girl
anime um
i don't know if i really watch anything
with women
and time
give it up for feminists morgan
and bernard white
he said uh i'm 23 and i saw bernard be
like oh [ __ ] this is
violating my probation
[Laughter]
is the last time you've been around a 23
year old woman bernard
since i was programming on ea
you're at work you were hanging around a
lot of
23 year olds game programmer you're
always around young people yeah that's
pretty cool so you work in tech
you used to yes
nice
and then we moved on to past atari and
you're like oh i'm out of my element
yeah yep
gotta love that freaking
good old elder scrolls you know bit map
of like eight bits
eight bit map
that's funny because uh you look like an
8-bit character
like
if wreck-it ralph became a more diverse
city inclusive
you look like you have a good james earl
jones impression oh yeah probably the
force is in you
i want some mcdonald's now yeah
i do
what do you think about this beautiful
black couple
we love it
yeah we're like a power couple i'm like
jay-z an anime couple
yeah
how did you know she watched anime i
mean you do have an anime vibe but
i i'm sorry
i think so i'm sorry
[Music]
that's kind of true the people i have
sex with
have
[Laughter]
uh okay cool yeah i mean if you have
sense of black people
then every black man you had sex with
knows dragon ball z oh yeah
i will ask them next time
the answer will be yes for dragon ball z
super yeah okay okay i did watch dragon
ball z but in spanish so i it's still
funny it's still good yeah it's still
good
no medigas
[Laughter]
i have no idea i don't watch dragon ball
z and i'm [ __ ] asian
i feel like we only make anime for black
people now this
is like thanks
sorry for the
thank you for anime
thank you very much
i'm just kidding i think she just swore
at me in japanese
and thank you for the blue girl
the blue girl
i'm blue
[Laughter]
you're
welcome that's our contribution
[Laughter]
that and uh you know whatever blurred
genitals
so uh bernard uh so did you mention
anime just because i was up here or is
that something that you ask on every day
that i asked on every day and how does
that usually go for you if you don't
know anime they're not worthy
nice you have your standards you know
what you like yup yup
uh
morgan uh do you have you ever like
talked about anime on a date before um i
try not to because i feel like they'll
judge me for everything they'll be like
trying to test me on things right
and you're trying to get
[Laughter]
it's like when you're talking to a
vaccinated person and they're they're
like i'm boosted twice
what's the uh craziest anime that you've
seen um
i don't know probably innu yashiki
i'm dead
[Music]
i'm learning about my culture right now
i'm not worthy
let me tell you about uh you know um
that tupac movie he was in
i don't know
some black stuff that i could
out of compton yeah
you guys heard of nwa uh
what's that
oh what does it stand for neighbors
i don't know tell me who was in there
acronym what is it what does it mean
it just means uh you know like people
that are kind of fed up with things
[Laughter]
people petitioning their government
loudly in public
uh so anime uh what do you guys uh what
do you guys think uh
would you guys ever do like some uh some
role-playing like
naughty professor i'll be barrett i can
do a good barrett
i don't know if i'll do any role
i feel like you would just like vanilla
you just laughed
[Music]
that she is vanilla
[Music]
stuff wow
well you're in luck because
bernard has a very very large foot
yeah
they're very beautiful 13 and a half
yeah
i don't mind bernard what are you into
are you into feet
i am a
focused and dedicated [ __ ] eater
[Music]
that's not the only thing you've been
eating
[Laughter]
suspected
so uh how do you eat it like uh what's
your technique
so i suck in the [ __ ] and just like box
it with my tongue
oh my god
you box it yeah
yeah he clipped boxes
[Laughter]
can you do it into the mic just like how
you box a box of
clips my god y'all feeling that
i just can't that was some professional
[ __ ] eating right i have to go home
[Laughter]
don't say do you think that bernard is
uh you think he's talking a big game or
do you think he can back it up no i
think bigger guys are good at eating
[ __ ]
they're good at eating everything
that's kind of the problem like skinny
guys have republican sex and that's not
always fun you know
the skinny guys don't really want to get
dirty they're like you no they're like
my tongue
goodbye
get your own uber make your own things
i think those are just poor guys that
work at ibm and don't spend their own
money yeah well he has money
he just they don't want to spend it on
other people and they don't want to eat
[ __ ]
yeah they're just like i'm not eating
anything yeah
i'm just gonna be skinny and like
[ __ ] just sit here and let everyone
work because i have no energy because
i'm on a vegan diet oh maybe that's why
you guys
yeah but bernard here
yeah he could go for days
you just give him a snorkel
panties no panties he doesn't care he
eats at all
when i'm done there will be no panties
and you won't be able to find them
either he's the burger and the rapper
he eats the panties
bernard is a goat
the greatest of all time
they worship him at satanic temples
yeah you're
finally someone better than grant came
up here
yeah he was hard to beat and he's
drinking water yeah
you can get water for the ladies i had
like three open mics back to back i had
water
yeah you gotta you gotta pace yourself
you wanna stay hydrated you don't wanna
get dry down there
all
all night
you have the uh hair of frederick
douglass
that's racist
it's black history month
look at his hair from from the neck up
he looks like he's gonna like talk some
[ __ ]
a little bit here douglas
a little bit
that dug life
who's your favorite uh
civil rights or uh
african-american
leader
is this odd
someone's cutting his mic off
i think it's the fbi there
here to assassinate you
well my favorite is mr van peebles
mr van peeples is that a dutch guy he is
a black director
a lot of black exploitation films
nice
he knows all that [ __ ] he knows anime he
knows black exploitation
he's like an indie he's like
an indie guy he's like i was there
before it was popular
it is true i love trauma bill too the
real hipster
morgan who is your favorite uh
black leader
favorite black leader um
there's so many uh
it may be like uh uh
bernard white i don't know either of
them
marcus garvey
i think i drove on his street or
something
i just picked a random black face
i think he was like the mayor of like
atlanta or something well he wanted to
send all the
black people back to africa
right that sounds racist no no he just
wanted them to connect with their roots
oh like a birthright yeah he's like okay
he's like uh we need to treat black
people like jews that'll really help
um my favorite blacklist
my favorite asian leader would have to
be uh ho chi minh now
mao zedong he did that little thing
where he starved like seven million
chinese people
i guess he's not valid
yeah
he doesn't slap he doesn't
he's not lit
pool pot
the killing fields
um but uh yeah so you guys
would uh if you guys would go on a date
where do you guys think you would go and
what do you guys think you'd do there
well a lot to eat i'll take the perry
steakhouse
never heard of perry's steakhouse but i
would eat at perry's steakhouse
steakhouse
uh where would you like to go on a date
this is so hard
i don't really go places
god
maybe you could watch anime yeah we
could just watch anime eat some popcorn
next cook some chill
yeah make food at the house
smoke a little bud you know yeah
something chill you know yeah we don't
have to spend money
what a good uh you know
she's uh she doesn't want to participate
in the uh what the economy or whatever
save money
so um
bernard what kind of people do you date
racially like whites or blacks or asians
mostly everything but black
everything but black
bernard is honest to a fault
he hates black women
i was raised by nine military black
women overseas for 10 years in germany
you tell me how i feel
nine military black women is this a new
tyler perry movie coming out
it should be
that sounds intense yeah they were all
in the military yes
all of them was single mothers so we had
all these kids
[Laughter]
yes
dulce what do you think about this
couple
i think
um they could be best friends
friends sound great
i'm a good friend
what a good friend
hell yeah
fist bump
well i'm gonna get you guys out of here
before the police are called
it's racist
[Music]
give it up for bernard and morgan
what'd you get what'd you think of all
the dates tonight i loved it
uh grant was my favorite because he got
me a drink so nice that's all it takes
then take note start buying things
stop watching uh netflix at home stop
praising goats
start spending that money
um well that was the show
yeah it was fun uh you can follow dolce
mac on instagram
duel say thank you i'll say mac it's my
second language
um
i'm hans kim uh you can check other
people out every sunday here at 6 00 pm
thank you guys so much have a great
night thank you guys so much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you